boris johnson and his wife carrie leave
number 10 downing street for the final
time it was the first act in a carefully
choreographed handover of power
that saw liz trust become britain's new
prime minister
outside on the steps of the official
residence johnson said his final
goodbyes
thank you thank well
well this is
this is it folks in only a couple of
hours i will be in balmoral to see her
majesty the queen and the torch will
finally be passed to a new conservative
leader
let me say that i am now like one of
those booster rockets
that has fulfilled its function
and i will now be gently re-entering the
atmosphere and splashing down invisibly
in some remote and obscure corner of the
pacific
and i will be supporting liz truss and
the new government every step of the way
thank you all very much thank you and
goodbye thank you
[Applause]
boris johnson and liz trust then headed
to scotland for the next part of their
performance they visited the queen at
her residence at belmoral castle johnson
was in first to officially tender his
resignation
he then left no longer prime minister
and once he was gone
truss arrived at balmoral for her
audience with the queen
and the british monarch formally invited
her to form a new government
she then headed to her new official
residency number 10 downing street where
she addressed the nation for the first
time as prime minister in her speech she
praised her predecessor and vowed to
tackle the challenges facing britain
head on
i have just accepted her majesty the
queen's
kind invitation to form a new government
now is the time to tackle the issues
that are holding britain back as prime
minister i will pursue three early
priorities
firstly i will get britain working again
secondly i will deal hands-on with the
energy crisis caused by putin's war
thirdly i will make sure that people can
get doctors appointments and the nhs
services they need
we will put our health service on a firm
footing
i am determined to deliver
thank you
and quentin peele is with me now to talk
about the new british prime minister
he's an associate fellow with the europe
program at the chatham house think tank
mr peel good to see you
the list of promises is long how will
this trust go about delivering
well she's basically got to stand on
their heads most of the things that she
promised during her campaign
she said she's going to go for tax cuts
and no subsidies in fact she's going to
have to have enormous subsidies to try
and put a cap on the energy prices and
she's going to have to spend a huge
amount of money on the national health
service on defense
so actually she's going to be quite a
spender and not a saver
she lost no time to reshuffle the
cabinet did she hers is very diverse
quite young very much out of her own
wing of the party did she pick the right
team for the ride ahead
well it's certainly been criticized
already as being quite lightweight not
particularly experienced although in
many ways it looks quite like the
johnson government that it replaces so
there are quite a lot of people there
who were in the former government
although several heavyweights have gone
like the deputy prime minister for
example dominic grab and uh
she's brought in people who were clearly
her supporters and it's
quite clear that she's rewarding their
loyalty
the other most interesting thing is
really that the three biggest jobs in
government have all gone to members of
ethnic minorities you've got a black
chancellor exchequer in quasi-quatern
um a black foreign secretary in james
cleverley and uh british asian
uh
suella brotherman as the home secretary
that's quite striking in terms of the
normal male white cabinets that the
british have seen
the conservative party is in a bad state
though deeply divided
will she be able to get everyone to
rally around her you think
she's going to have a real struggle i
think i mean this this succession battle
and the replacement of johnson has been
a very miserable and bitter affair
they've been squabbling very openly and
she didn't get a resounding endorsement
in her election i mean actually she
didn't even get half the
members of the conservative party
tobacco and she got quite a poor showing
also from members of parliament so she's
going to have quite a struggle it's
possible that she may not last very long
if she can't hold her party together but
she has a big majority in parliament
thanks to the majority that boris
johnson won
at the last election 80-seat majority
which should see her through the danger
being that when you've got a big
majority people feel much more able to
rebel against you so she's going to have
to woo people quite
assiduously she's going to have to work
very hard at this and as you perhaps
heard from her speech she's not a very
persuasive sort of person she's rather
dull very different to boris johnson in
that way she doesn't have any of his
humor and his flair
let's zoom out a bit what does her
appointment as prime minister mean for
the uk's position in the world
well um
i fear that it doesn't mean a huge
amount of change i mean she has made her
name a bit at the foreign ministry
as somebody who was tough towards the
european union she's the one who's
tabled the legislation to scrap the
so-called northern ireland protocol
which is a vital piece of legislation to
enable the whole trade
trade situation with the european union
to work properly if she's going to scrap
that against the signing that boris
johnson did of it then that's going to
poison relations with the european union
the question is will she change her mind
and the truth is we don't really know
this is a woman who looks on the one
hand as a very
ideological sort of person but on the
other hand she was once a remainer she
wanted to stay in the eu and then she
became a fierce brexiter somebody wanted
to leave the eu and i think we're going
to have to wait and see how she works
out in power